Hello, and welcome to this intelligence squared podcast with me Cole Miller.
I'm delighted today to introduce our guest Phillip Rowley futures,
director of Omnicom,
who joins me to discuss how COVID-19 will shape the next decade of culture
and entertainment. A quick reminder, of course,
if you enjoy today's podcasting forgets,
press the like button and subscribe to the channel.
And if you have strong views on our discussion,
let us know what you think in the comment section below. So feel hi. Hello.
How are you? Very good. So let's, let's begin Phil, um, with, um,
what what's a features director actually is. Um,
what do you actually spend your day actually doing.
Well? I work for Omnicom media group. Uh, and so my role ultimately is to, uh,
use, uh, insight and turn it into foresight about where, um,
where things are headed over the next decade and specifically how that pertains
to brands and businesses. Um, and really sort of effectively, not just,
um, uh, casting forward to a distant intangible future,
but understanding the route to that future so that we can make things, um,
actionable and tangible in the now, um,
so that they don't either take us by surprise or we don't position them in such
a fashion that seems so distant that, that,
that brands and business don't feel they have to worry about it.
So we always say that the future isn't a pin in the map, it is the map.
And so it's really helping navigate towards, uh, the,
the technological developments, um,
and societal and cultural developments we think, uh, we'll see over the next,
say five or.
10 Years. And what's your kind of compass then on this map,
like kind of what, what,
what's your actual way of thinking about this in terms of like evidence or data,
or how do you kind of pull things together to start to start actually drawing it
all? Yeah.
That's a great question. I mean, I think that the, the, one of the, our key,
I suppose,
approaches is to imagine a futurism as a discipline that can be learned and
taught, um,
rather than just a series of random overbearing prognostications.
Um, our chief, um, our compass, I suppose, is to, uh,
look at the broad territories, which we think that we will,
that we'll be developing over the next sort of five, 10 years,
but then find the entry point, um, in, in the here and now. Uh,
and one of the things that we hear from, you know,
a lot of brands and businesses is that they think that innovation is distant or
expensive or too difficult to do.
And our job really is to teach futurism is disciplined by showing them where the
entry door is to all of those territories in the now or showing where the bottom
rung of the ladder is. And, and,
and effectively plan out that route in incremental improvements.
I think people tend to forget that innovation is something that happens
incrementally, um, and, and evolves rather than a sort of spontaneous,
um, disruptive moment, which everybody seems to, to, to,
to glom on to in, in, in the press.
So it's really about talking that route to the future and teaching futurism as
it is.
Well talking of disruptive moments,
let's drag ourselves back into those kinds of fateful of kind of February and
March. I dunno what you were doing. I mean,
I was barricading myself into my home writing panic, shopping lists,
sundries, and frozen foods to buy. But, um, in,
in those kinds of early weeks where you, was,
it really apparent to you that that actually thinking about the future and
especially the,
the further future was going to be a really important thing to do?
Absolutely. I mean, just on a personal level, um,
I find my mind turning to things like, how can I,
what do I actually need if I need to hunker down, you know,
what can I get online? What's loaded up into the cloud,
what files can I access if I don't have to go buy, uh, go back to work.
So there was that sort of idea of, you know,
developing a remote life strategy or a strategy for remote life,
but on a broader level and a business level.
When you work in media marketing and communications,
you also start immediately thinking of the implications for the clients that you
work on and trying to understand how that business can be conducted remotely
and using sort of the, the, the hyper-connectivity, uh, of, of the modern era.
And those are the things that I started thinking about.
But of course the other thing I started to think about is, um, you know,
what are they short-term and long-term implications about what we're about to
say, how is society going to change?
What behaviors are going to stick long after this is, this is a distant memory.
And I find myself filtering those in to the conversations that we're having on a
day-to-day basis. And realizing that a strategy, um,
was going to have to emerge from this, for us to advise our clients accordingly.
And I suppose exactly that,
that kind of discussion around what the implications of all of this really are,
is, has probably been more discussed and Moldova and, and, and,
and argued over, over this time, we spent locked down in our,
in our houses and almost anything else I can think of, um, as a,
as a kind of professional, um, how, uh, how, where people,
firstly kind of got it wrong,
where what the kind of like Phantom trends that maybe we're,
we're obsessing too much over an unthink gloom, uh,
two large Overwatch futures that like.
Yeah. Um, I don't think anybody's, uh,
identified any trends that necessarily won't come true.
I would turn it back the other way and say, I think people are confusing,
the short-term with the long-term. Um, and that's the Phantom trend.
This idea that whatever's happening right now is the new normal.
We keep hearing this phrase, the new normal as if, um, you know,
a lot of the trends that we are seeing a lot of the changes and impacts that we
are seeing, uh, when now irreversible, well, we know that's not true. You know,
it's certainly in our line of business,
we were told that cinema's cinema advertising is down outdoor advertising is
down, um, TV viewing is up and streaming is up. And of course those things, um,
we're not going to remain high forever.
Of course they were always going to fall back down to more natural levels when
the sort of inline with the peak actually. Um,
I think people are getting confused,
the short term aspects of those sort of peaks with the sort of along, um,
the long tail or,
or perhaps the slow climb of those trends wants to have bedded in and stick and
feel more integrated into society effectively. Now,
I think COVID-19 like a giant sampling campaign for certain technologies and
technologic driven behaviors.
And it's not that everyone will now all of a sudden be living a life like ready
player one internal,
but it is those people who have simpled certain things have tried delivering for
the first time,
have signed up to Netflix for the first time that they may continue to use
those, or it might be an option for the first time when it hasn't been before.
And so therefore it's that sort of much more subtle weaving in of these
behavioral changes that we'll see maybe, um, um,
take root in the next decade rather than this peak of, Oh my goodness,
this is happening, you know, um, this is happening now and will,
and will always be this way.
And that's the thing that people are getting confused, I think.
And w w what are to, to boil it down, let let's,
let's kind of go through some of the, kind of, uh,
like a long-term trend that really is a short-term trend. So is that,
is that things like kind of office working, um, or, um,
the death of the high street, you know, there's a lot,
there's lots of extremely exaggerated prognostications happening at the moment
about, about how it changed things would be,
which of those do you think really we'll actually,
we'll learn lean more towards no matter. See, again.
I think that's, that's a great question. I think that when you take a trend,
which is being prophesied in the extreme short term,
like it's sh like it's a long-term trend.
What you have to do is just take it down a couple of notches.
I'm not saying that that trend will never happen. So instead of saying,
everybody will work from home in the future, and of course, we've all seen, uh,
reports of Silicon Valley companies saying, you know, what,
you don't even need to come in again. Um,
I think if you just downgrade that three or four notches,
I think flexibility is something that we'll see moving in the future,
inherent flexibility in our working partners.
So the idea that everybody will work for home forevermore is of course,
a Phantom trend, but it's less a cousin it's smaller, more,
perhaps more modest,
more nuanced version of that trend is the thing that will take root over the
longterm, which, which is indeed flexibility. Same goes for the,
the trend that you've, that you also named there,
which I think is a great example, which is the high street. Now, of course,
everyone's saying the high street is dead, or, you know, there are lots of,
you know, terrible, uh, apocalyptic predictions. Um, again, it's,
it's perhaps in the short term, that might be true, but over the long-term,
the high street does have a role to play. And, you know,
we've been doing a lot of thinking about what a future high street might look
like coming off the back of COVID in five to 10 years. And again,
that lesser cost that more modest version of that perhaps doom Laden
prognostication is ultimately that, you know,
the high street will be much more digitally driven and much more digitally
integrated into its, into its offline, excuse me, into its online equivalent.
Um, and again, that's, I think that's the way we see things unfolding. Rather,
nothing is binary, nothing is doom Laden, or, you know,
perfectly utopian and optimistic.
It will in fact be a sort of subtle mesh of both really over a longer period.
Okay, well, let's go to the kind of mirror image of the Phantom trend,
which I haven't managed to find a good word for yet, but the,
because let, let, let's, let's talk about the, the, the longer term Jensen,
the genuine, you know, um, trajectories, which,
which you see all wrapped up in society.
And I I'd like to begin with the ones which, um,
are least visible to us. So, um,
w w what are the kind of bubbling kind of, um,
kind of changes in society that you see that, that probably, uh,
furthest away from people's kind of recommending and, and, and kind of, um,
conscious kind of a thought at the moment? Yeah.
Yeah. I think that my first answer to that would be one that may be seemingly
counter-intuitive or potentially mildly controversial.
And that is that I think we may be able to,
or we might be at bounce to enter into an age of innovation. Um,
one of the things that I was listening to commentators talk about prior to
COVID, uh, was, uh,
the fact that there was a lot of VC cash washing around at the moment.
And there was a lot of very,
very historically low interest rates and a sort of coming proxy war,
almost like the cold war, but,
but in innovation war between superpowers that wanted to demonstrate their
prowess, um, through technological and innovative accomplishment.
And that was sort of prior now, um, I think that that is something that again,
will be accelerated and ramped up the learnings from 2008.
The crash was that you can't cut your way out of these situations.
You have to kind of grow and innovate your way out.
I never a better proving or testing field than this pandemic for
large tech companies and businesses and brands,
and everyday people to see this as an opportunity to innovate their way out.
And of course,
maybe some of that VC cash is not floating around as much as it was. Um,
but, um,
the interest rates are still low and we are still in an extremely sort of,
what's the word I'm looking for, um, uh, software company competition,
maybe not so subtle competition with some of our global competitors for
innovation prowess. And I think, again, over the longer term, the, the,
the invisible trend that we're not talking about is that we potentially are
about to reap the benefits of this, uh,
of people with admittedly egos like Bezos and Musk and all the rest of it who
think this is a fantastic challenge for me to answer for me to leave my imprint
on society,
for me to demonstrate that we have the solution to everything and bring all
those forces to bear, whether it be Silicon Valley or VC cash,
or this ability to, um, uh, to,
to sort of solve the global issues is the thing that may give us a real boost
and, and bring us into this potentially an area of innovation.
Are we, are we likely, that's so interesting.
So are we likely to see innovation happening in like unfamiliar places?
So we, you know, we've got the kind of digital services, we've got AI,
emerging technology. Um, I presumably, you know,
in medicine and pharmaceuticals,
but I bet kind of other areas where you see kind of innovation,
maybe coming slightly kind of more out of left field.
I think that the area of innovation that we're most likely to, uh,
that's most likely to have blindsided us because it's not within common parlance
of most everyday people is this idea of deep tech, uh,
which I'm not sure if you're aware of which again is tech technology,
which is designed to solve really big existentialist issues that costs
hundreds of millions and billions of, uh, of pounds to solve,
because it's not on the radar of most people. And when I'm talking about that,
I'm talking about things like the lab grown meat, um, and, uh, and,
um, artificial intelligence as well. Now,
now I know that they are not a direct response to the pandemic,
and you could say, well,
how is the lab grown meat going to get us out of the problem with the pandemic?
It's really just a series of dominoes knocking against one another.
So the answer is, you know,
I think that we're about to see some profound existential it's life-changing
technologies accelerated as a result of COVID not as a direct
response, but more as a sort of knock on effect of,
because of this sort of time of innovation as a response to, uh,
almost a restate of humanity's genius and its ability to solve problems.
Use the word accelerated there, which was a brilliant cue for my,
for my next question. So, um, that,
that is the word that's often being used, um, kind of, um, to,
to describe what's happening, you know,
the idea that the coronavirus and the lockdown has accelerated a
series of trends that are happening already. What do you think about that? Is,
is that really true or are there kind of actual,
genuine new directions rather than just accelerations that have happened over
the last year?
Yeah, I mean, we've looked at quite closely at this and,
and I'm not going to be as arrogant enough to assume that there are no examples
of new trends, but we've certainly not found any compelling, new trends,
rather everything that we feel that will be accelerated over the long-term as a
result of COVID were trends that were bubbling under the surface. Anyway,
they had had prior discussion that had been predicted prior. Um, and so,
yeah, I, I'm not sure, uh, unless anyone who wants to countermand my example,
that we've seen anything new, rather we see that, uh, you know,
effectively the escalator has been turned to double speed and everything that
was going to happen as happening a lot quicker. The analogy I use is,
is it's a bit like the scene in back to the future,
to where doc Brown says that we've been the,
that Marty's been knocked on onto to an alternative 1985.
And he draws a diagram on the Blackboard.
I think of that everything that was going to happen,
we are now in an alternative 20, 25 or on routes to an alternative 20, 25,
where everything that would've happened will now happen sooner,
had COVID not happened. If that makes sense.
Are there any trends that we're accelerating,
but were really important that kind of have that have driven into a wall as a
there? So are there any kind of like stopped trends?
Wow. Um, uh,
the only way that I can think of that a trend would be stocked in the short term
is due to a lack of funding. Um, you know,
when we talked to our clients about the fact that they should be innovating,
naturally, they want to tell us, um,
how they restricted budgets or their budgets are restricted.
So you could take all the trends that we predict coming down the line.
And we can go into more detail about specifically what those trends are. Um,
all I'd say is, I don't think any will be stopped,
but many potentially may have an,
an initial sort of hump to go over whilst people attempt to save money.
But again, you know, my, my,
my statement on that is that I think that's a mistake.
I know it's easy for me to sit here and tell them to spend money when,
of course they need cutbacks. But one of the learnings,
as I mentioned from 2008, is that, you know,
these trends can only be stopped by people assuming that money is not the
answer,
but in many cases spending and innovating the way out of the situation is
exactly the answer. And that's what we've seen.
Okay. Well, so let's, let's dig into some of these trends, a little deeper. Um,
and the first one I want to begin with is one that I know an enormous number of
people are thinking about, worried about it's the, it's the right, you know,
the, the rise and rise and rise and rise and rise of the tech giants. Um,
how much more powerful have they become over the lockdown and,
and what do you think the kind of implications of that really are?
Okay. So I think they've, of course,
due to the fact that we're just all using them, um, considerably more,
or they have, uh, seen a considerable rise in their power. However,
what I also think is, um,
I think that there is increasing awareness of how much power that they have over
us. This is not some kind of invisible or Wesleyan, uh, um, oversight.
I think people are increasingly aware of how much they're being tracked and how
much more they are using the services of the tech giants. Um,
and as a result, um,
one potential sort of knock on effect might be counter intuitive,
and it might be counterproductive to the, to, to, to,
to the tech giants is that we may see, uh, potentially a privacy fight Mack,
which again, to, to,
to the earlier point is something that was bubbling under the surface. Anyway,
um, we have seen, um, not just tech giants actually,
but governments as well use contact tracing. And in certain countries,
this is used as, almost as a method of enforcement.
We've seen smart city control rooms pop up. Um, in India, we have seen, uh,
drones, um, where I'm from in,
Darbyshire trying to tell people to go home and, and, and even if people,
even if people aren't more monitored than before they at least feel that they're
being more monitored before they feel, uh,
that you know that Facebook and Google and Amazon know more about them before,
and that might lead them to seek out private privacy solutions.
Now you can actually see VPNs versatile virtual personal networks advertised in
the middle of coronation street on ITV now. And I,
and this is something that you can download effectively to, to,
to sort of make your,
make your life a lot easier and make you feel more comfortable that you're not
being tracked. And also at a startup conference last year in Finland, I saw, um,
the introduction of something called data anonymizes,
which effectively is something that you can download onto your computer,
whether it be an app or a small, um, uh,
computer program running in the background that effectively covers your tracks
in the snow. Um,
or another way of saying it would be to scribble out selected letters on a,
on a P on a piece of writing metaphorically so that people can't piece together
who you are or what you've done. Um,
and the way that works instantly is by spamming the algorithm with something
called synthetic data.
So it gives the algorithm so much contradictory information to, to, to,
to calculate that it sort of loses any sense of who you are.
And so when they become common, common use,
that means that the tech giants may have a challenge to their ability to apply
their trade with so much efficiency,
because effectively they're selling or they're buying your attention,
but they're also in return buying certain pieces of information in order to sell
you goods and services. And there's not a problem with that,
as long as people know that they are being tracked accordingly,
but you might see, um, that sort of a, you know, a set of tools,
which allow citizens to counteract that fact as a result of the pandemic.
So what about kind of decentralization, um, um, data unions.
Do,
do you think there's this kind of whole other kind of countervailing trend in a
way,
which at some point it's going to kind of smash into the kind of centralizing
data, aggregating data, hungry,
insatiable appetite of the, of the platforms that,
that themselves are getting so much bigger.
Potentially. Um, I mean,
I hate to mention the B and the C word blockchain and crypto coin, but,
um, because it's sort of had a bit of a bad rap recently,
certainly as an investment,
but I think one of the underlying principles about those technologies and what's
interesting is it allows people to sort of play their trade on a decentralized
and an anonymous basis. And if nothing else,
the learnings from those two technologies might be once they become available to
the general public and understandable,
and usable and functional to the general public, they may, as you say,
be the direct counter trends to this idea of, uh, of, of, uh,
of collecting data together. Um, and in which case, you know,
we ha we have strategies Omnicom for sort of getting round and circumventing
that in. And I don't mean legally, I mean, in the sense that, you know,
there are other ways for brands and businesses to talk to their customers
without necessarily having to, you know,
store huge amounts of information about them. But, um, that is, uh, yeah,
I agree there, there, there is potentially a tension point between those two,
um, on the horizon.
Let's go to, um,
let's go away from data and over to decision-making. So,
so you mentioned governments a bit already do,
is that another kind of focal or principle trend that you see that almost is
kind of changing relationship between governments and the governments?
I think so. Um,
and I think that's typified by the fact that we see a lot of big governments.
Um, we, we see a lot of big government,
so governments taking top-down control of their societies during a crisis,
but we see it from conservative governments,
which have traditionally have been the parties of, um, of small government.
And of course, they've had to do that as a result of, um, uh, of, uh,
of the crisis. But I think the way that they've done that, um,
partially is through the use technology in the way we've just discussed with the
tech giants, but also through the use of connectivity. Uh, and, and, and,
you know, it's really interesting that, um, many of the, uh,
five government led 5g programs around the world have been accelerated as a
result of this crisis. Um, in order to, um, ensure equality of access,
you would say, um, uh, on the face of it,
but actually to your point is to ensure that they can govern their citizens
better. I mean, a couple of examples,
Telstra in Australia who are the Australian telecommunications company have
brought forward their 5g development and invested an extra $500 million.
They was provisioned in the $10 billion FCC bailout that Trump signed off for,
um, addressing, um,
rural communities that don't have a proper connectivity so that they can't be
governed to. I suppose, to, to a certain extent,
they had 10 million people fall into what they call the homework gap.
So kids couldn't do their homework because their internet was too slow.
And then in this country, of course, we have 5g, uh,
mass being put up all over the place. And,
and then we have quad away in the mix, which might obfuscate, uh, um, the,
that the development of that that's all part and parcel that 5g development of
governments wanting to ensure equality of access and to govern their citizens
through these technological systems off the back of what we've seen, um,
during the pandemic, even conservative governments,
which you could argue are not into spending big.
What do you think is going to happen to trust? Um, cause one of the, I mean,
I, I mean trusting kind of, of individuals in kind of all big institutions,
so be that a corporate or a government, because I mean,
it's hard to talk about futures around coronavirus, but of course,
mentioning conspiracy theories, the info dynamic, you know, and the, uh,
basically they're kind of organized mobilized resistance to the
epidemiologically driven consensus around, around the lockdown.
And how significant do you think that que and on conspiracy theories in
general are kind of as a, as a new cultural force?
I think they're incredibly significant. Um, I think that we've seen trust,
take an absolute nosedive. Um, uh, again,
this is not something that is new during the new there's new as a result of
pandemic, but something that's been accelerated where, um,
effectively propaganda has been democratized,
anybody that who has access to a keyboard can, can state something without,
without recourse ultimately, or certainly, uh, can say something without,
without, um, being sued so easily. Um,
I think that we are going to have to, this sort of keeps me awake at night.
Actually. I think we are going to have to find a better functioning system for
establishing trust. Um, and I don't know what that looks like.
I don't know where for it's used, if,
if we use some kind of certification to demonstrate, um,
the provenance and Providence of information,
I don't know if it contains something that's built around something like a
digital watermark, which ultimately, uh, um, uh,
signifies the veracity of the origin of a piece of information. Again,
going back to the, sort of the, the, the blockchain, um,
argument that might be a way of somehow ensuring that something is, um,
for one of a better word, um, uncorruptable to a certain extent, but this is,
I think that trust is the biggest issue facing society today,
particularly given the decentralization of truth, if you like. Um,
and the fact that anyone can, anyone with a computer can, can, uh,
make proclamations, which don't, which don't have to be backed up.
And that has real implications for government.
It has real implications for brands and businesses,
and it has real implications for citizens,
and it's something that somebody really needs to solve.
And I'm afraid I don't have the answer to it in the short term.
Because at least to me, it kind of really feels like there's,
there's something of an earthquake rumbling under lots of our kind of pillows,
institutional pillars,
like they're going to BBC or professional journalists or government,
or the police service, you know, where there's this kind of, you know,
Morris of locked down plus online influence operations and someone is
really shaking it. What would say, say,
just to go pessimistic for a second feel,
we don't manage to kind of engineer ourselves to kind of trust solution, um,
to say trust continues to decline and in the kind of slightly longer time,
kind of what,
w what does a society with very low levels of trust actually look like?
And is that something that say, you know, corporates companies and so on,
really have to start thinking about that?
I think so. I think my view is,
is that we will descend into a series of extremely discreet network tribes so
that, you know, the national borders will break down and we'll actually,
we will seek to disassociate ourselves with those that we feel are
untrustworthy.
And what you'll get is this sort of atomization or a virtual optimization,
because it won't be a long street lines or national lines, or even cross lines.
It will be sort of networked across borders with people who you feel you have
shared with common values. And so I think that we'll see us sort of,
kind of a multi-layered thing of society,
which is based on people with shared values,
rather than any other kind of social construct that for business and brands
means that they have a sort of new set of target markets rather than, you know,
um, you know, uh,
should we say men 16 to 34 it's attitude and all target markets or
attitudes or sets where they feel that they can, uh,
cover off quite a few people with a particular messaging opportunity by
appealing to a, you know, a disparate but connected group of people,
rather than a vertical cohort based on any kind of usual
socioeconomic demographics. Um, and that we don't want to get to that situation,
because that means that it's very,
very difficult to build bridges between those disparate, uh,
and discrete targets, but it is something that I think might come out of, um,
a situation where we don't solve that trust issue using potentially a
technological solution that you, as the way you just mentioned.
Well, to turn to something a little lighter, I think for our, I lost,
I lost kind of big trends to dig into as,
as everyone else was doing wholesome things like baking banana bread.
I was getting my PS4 back out and I can't imagine I'm alone in kind of turning
back to gaming. Um, during the lockdown what's happened there,
what's happening in gaming.
We've seen a massive increase in gaming. Um,
and this is a piece of work that we're doing at the moment, um,
which we think that there's going to be,
this is one of the perfect examples of how long-term change will come out of the
pandemic. And a couple of things to say on this. First of all,
more people are gaming than ever before, or were more gaming than ever before,
before the pandemic. And now, of course, that has rocketed, not least because,
um, um, obviously people have been at home,
but also because people are taking up at the same time, um, hyper casual gaming,
which is the, just using it on your phone or using it on an app,
and people don't even consider themselves gamers,
but they're just sort of playing a quick round of Scrabble whilst they're,
whilst they're waiting for the kettle to boil or whatever.
So there are more people gaming than ever before that comes at the same time.
As more people are sort of static and stationary than ever before,
but it also comes at a time when the gaming companies themselves
are developing the technology to such a point that you can now have,
um, other media ensconced within gaming environments.
So on animal crossing, we've seen TV chat shows within animal crossing.
We have seen Travis Scott perform a concert within fortnight and achieved
27.7 million views. Um,
we have seen people learning, um, within gaming environments.
There are minor lessons in Minecraft now,
a science lessons and history lessons in Minecraft. Um,
and what we actually think that we will see is that gaming will swallow all of
the media. Um,
emotional influence said that every new media swallows the previous media,
so there was originally writing and then radio came along and added audio and
took stories within it within its purview.
And then TV came along and swallowed radio and added visuals.
And the internet came along and swallowed TV,
which contained radio and writing, and now gaming will swallow everything.
Not because that it would be necessarily be bigger than all of those things,
but because it can contain all of those things. And soon,
I don't think that we will need the word gaming anymore because that just refers
to computerized competition. We'll need a different word for it. Um,
spatial computing is one that's been used or virtual media is another,
but that sort of has connotations again of VR headsets,
which I think is inaccurate. But the biggest change,
I think from a media perspective to come out of COVID is that, that,
that this idea is gaming will morph into a channel of channels that will contain
all the, all the channels inside it and be the glue between them.
And that's going to have enormous significance just as quick example,
if anybody under the age of, sorry, excuse me.
If anyone over the age of 40 has never been on Twitch,
go and watch Twitch for half an hour. It is bewildering and confusing.
And yet at the same time, you know,
that that's what the future of media will look like. Everything is on there,
there is people spectating, other people watching games.
There's a social layer over the top there's music on there.
There's celebrities on there, they're sporting fixtures on there.
That's what the future of media looks like.
It's confusing and has multiple parts and contains all of the media with
inside its platform. And that's what I think we'll see.
A really compelling. And when, when you, when you put it so eloquently,
it's hard to see how it's not going to happen. Um,
w w what would the implications,
so imagining a society 10 years from hence where we are maybe all
gamers without even really thinking we are gamers anymore,
because it's so ubiquitous, what are the implications of that for all of us,
do you think, um,
is that going to change the kind of society and who we know is going to change?
Well, we all become much better. Problem-solvers.
Are there any kind of personal consequences of all of this that people might
start to think about?
Yes. I think the danger is actually going back to my, to my previous point,
is that when we can associate, um,
virtually with anybody that we wish to associate with,
and you don't have to rub shoulders with the person on the side, on, on,
on the boss, that's speaking loudly on his phone.
I think it will just compound the echo chamber effect that we see are going on,
on social media during the pandemic, and before and after I think that,
you know,
when you can spend time interacting with people of your choice in a way of your
choosing and avail yourselves of entertainment, uh,
auctions and educational options, uh,
and almost be ultimately selective about your audience,
it may mean that we don't come into contact with any kind of people with any
kind of media with any kind of messaging or communication or thinking that we
wouldn't have ordinarily come into contact with.
So it could potentially compound that, um,
atomization and compartmentalization and science, social siloing, um,
and I don't know what we do about that. Um, but that is something that, uh,
it could be a potential consequence when we have ultimate choice when we can
draw any picture or painting that we want when we can listen to any sound that
we, that we wish to when we can, um, occupy any location, uh,
virtually that we want to, um, we may find that we, uh,
that we filter out the things that we didn't know were good for us, um,
that we were being exposed to against our choice. Um,
and that could be a potential.
How far away,
away from a major political party running a campaign on a,
within a virtual space?
Well, given
given that most political parties are perhaps a little bit slow to the punch,
uh, in, in, in my view, certainly in this country,
I don't think that it's going to be in the immediate,
I don't think it will be by the next election, I wouldn't imagine. Um,
but I think that certainly it will become part of a standard political
vocabulary, certainly within the next couple of decades.
I think Obama was one of the first people to embrace, um, micro-targeting,
uh, in the 2008 election. And,
and it wasn't really talked about very much because it wasn't very well
understood, but then of course, fast forward to Trump's election,
and then people were using it as an excuse to say that this is,
this is the reason why the election has been manipulated.
If there are any experiments in virtual spaces in politics at the moment.
I think that they're certainly not prominent enough to be part of the, uh,
of the discourse, uh, for a little while yet.
So Phil, in this kind of last kind of mini sections of talk,
I'm keen to kind of bring it, um, kind of back home to, to, to people,
um, people listening to this that I'm sure, um,
have found like lots to be optimistic about and maybe some things to be
pessimistic about in all the different trends that you've kind of woven together
and described. Um, is there any,
are there any trends amongst all that you see that first off,
it's kind of worth warning people about, you know,
the might impact them the most in a, in a way which will be negative,
but they really need to start planning and thinking about now?
Well, the exact point, I think that for many companies and for many, many, uh,
citizens that are sort of a plan B or a contingency plan may become a
standard practice or should it become a standard practice? Um, you know, when,
when I went to the supermarket on the first night that the pandemic looked like
it was going to get serious,
I went about eight 30 and all the shelves were empty and I started to get a
little bit panicked. And I think that if Penn,
if there was a pandemic came along again, or maybe not pandemic,
maybe another event of equal import, that was just as globally significant.
I would hope that supermarkets and businesses and people may have
developed, um, a contingency plan or a plan B, and that might involve, uh,
you know, um, stores of cash or stores of food, not sort of prepper standard,
but, you know, just knowing, knowing what they would do in a crisis,
because part of the panic that was driven that during those first week is people
had not had the experience of this before. Um, and so, yeah, I,
I would advise people in the same way as they take out insurance or,
or get fire alarms and carbon monoxide alarms, or, you know,
work out how to save for something that they have a sort of a mandated, um,
escape route and a backup plan for such situations in future,
because we have been found wanting, um, in this situation.
How about, um, how about jobs? So, so, you know, sadly of course,
you know, the, the furlough scheme winding down redundancies winding up,
there's probably people listening to this now that had a job a couple of months
ago that don't now, um, in, in the trends,
how can people react in the trends that you see to maybe think about new
industries or new sectors or new skills, um, you know, to,
to move into or acquire.
That's difficult to predict. I think, um, I've,
I think off the back of the pandemic,
obviously there are people who have lost their jobs, but again,
sort of in that longer term, I think that, you know,
that they will be found again, hopefully, um, as a result of things,
getting back to normal, but further down the line, I think just,
just the general, uh, efficiency drive and automation,
and robotization that we see of industry in general is something that is more
of more concern rather than the sort of post pandemic, uh, implications of, uh,
of the job market. And the things that I've read about in the past, um,
is really to try and move into, uh,
into work that doesn't age doesn't involve any kind of repetitive pattern,
because that's something that machine learning could pick up and repeat and,
and be a job that requires emotional intelligence is something that won't be,
um, that won't be a replicable in the short term.
So if you are an artist or a nurse, um,
or somebody that does something that isn't on a production line,
this is something that will hold you in good stead over time. Um, and,
and I think that's more keen to keep front of mind rather than anything that's
come out of the pandemic, which I think jobs will slowly recovering the midterm.
How about kind of other key life choices fill for people? So, you know,
I'm sure people are gonna try to sell their house, move to the country,
get away from, you know, I, I,
is there a danger that kind of people are actually making life choices based,
as you said on the kind of short term impression of how societies can change
actually, rather than what's going to look like two years from now.
I think there is it's the opposite.
I think there's a danger that they are not making decisions based on the short
term. So in other words,
people are holding off on things they're holding off on selling the house.
They're holding off on going on holiday, they're holding off on, uh, on a,
on an, on a new car. Uh,
and I'm not advocating necessarily that they go out and do all of these things
and throw caution to the wind,
not least because we have a set of instructions where it says, you know,
for the most part, trying to limit yourself to, to,
to congregating with less than six people. Um, so,
so I think that's more likely to have the short term is that everything's on
pause. So people it's not that people are making the wrong decisions.
I think people are taking no decisions because there's a whole wait and see
policy, uh, that is sort of embedded in our, in our, in our,
in our public consciousness in the moment.
And that has more impact on the economy.
And it has more impact on jobs as you've just mentioned,
the question you just mentioned then than anything else in my view.
Okay. Um, well, final question then, is this I suppose for what,
how can everyone be a bit more like you, um,
what ha how can people adopt a bit of a kind of future minded mentality or way
of thinking about these kinds of, um, these kinds of issues, because, um,
I'm sure we're all having to scan our own horizons at the moment and,
and any ways of doing that better, of course,
hugely hugely valuable for all of us.
I think it's, again,
separating that short-term from the long-term and understanding, you know,
predicting where you would like to be in five to 10 years and understanding the
needs States that you may have in those 10 years,
and then incrementally building towards those rather than reacting in the now or
not reacting in the now is as we've just said. So that's the first thing,
understanding the difference between long-term and short-term change.
The second thing is to search for smart solutions. Um,
there are plenty of smart solutions that have bubbled up zoom has,
has gone gangbusters since, since, uh, you know,
that the pandemic I was working on an interactive whiteboard program the other
day as well, which is really interesting as well. So, you know,
feel free to avail yourself as smart solutions, um,
which have been brought to the fore have been sampled or demonstrated, uh,
and make use of them and continue to make use of them if they work for you after
the pandemic is long gone.
And the third thing which I mentioned is have a plan is have a plan B,
a contingency plan, a backup escape route as well.
So if this did come along again, ensure that you have almost like, um,
in the way that a computer has safe mode, and it goes to a set of presets,
which allows the computer to keep functioning while you solve the problem,
have a set of your own presets,
which allow you to sort of fall back into a really sort of a position that
allows you to continue to function, um, last, um, was preparing for,
for what comes next.
Um, and then lastly, um, what about companies? So of course,
like lots of companies are trying to call themselves back into the pattern of
the business model, which, you know, has been so disrupted and undermined. Um,
is there a kind of other ways of thinking for companies and their leadership
at the moment, which you think in the kind of long term will allow, will,
will allow them to survive and to flourish in ways which other companies won't.
Yes. I think it's,
if you sell a physical product that people need to come and see,
or people pick off the shelf, or people want to smell touch, um,
it's it's to do two things, think about how that product looks in. Um, uh,
again, that sort of spatial environment,
how do you get your brand and your brand values, um, into, down,
down a broadband cable, um, effectively,
how can people use your product simply get a feel for it and learn as much about
it as possible? Um,
other than just sort of standard website when people aren't leaving the house as
much in the short or in, in indeed, indeed the midterm.
And the second thing is as well is when people do start move,
coming back to the high street and start physically moving around,
how can you can make it worth their while that they've actually got off their
sofas and come into your store,
what else can you offer them an experiential point of view, um,
that you think that will make metric worthwhile?
I think increasingly we'll see shops again, off the longterm,
off the back of this, um, that don't necessarily resemble shops. You know,
shops don't have to be shelves and shelves of items. Um,
they can look like chill out zones, even light laboratories.
They can look like gardens in order to make it so much more different, um,
for you to, you know, to, to, to,
to not choose this sort of dry functional e-commerce option.
And those are the things that I think companies can do virtualize the products,
but also make the physical, um, uh,
display and positioning of it compelling enough to make people to want to come
into store and see it and feel it and touch it and smell it.
Amazing. Well, Philip, thank you so much what a great discussion. Um,
and it's been,
it's been a real journey and I hope we've transported everyone into, into,
into this vision of 10 years, hence,
and everyone's now a little better forearmed and forewarned. Um,
thanks very much, everyone for listening.
You've been listening to intelligence squad and I'm Camila.